new research says that speeding is
almost as big a factor in deadly crashes
as drunk driving federal regulators say
nearly a third of deadly crashes from
2005 to 2014 were related to speed on
average more than 11,000 people are
killed in those kind of accidents every
year Kris Van Cleave is on Massachusetts
Avenue in Washington DC with the new
calls to increase efforts to crack down
on speeding Kris good morning good
morning drivers may hate them but
studies show speed cameras when properly
placed can significantly reduce speeding
which can make roads safer for drivers
and pedestrians but they're only legal
in less than a third of the country and
the NTSB says that needs to change we're
up to 60 miles per hour now she's going
to Levin over Fairfax County police
captain Michael Brennan has spent 24
years on patrol speeders are a daily
part of life any reason you're going
that fast what's the biggest challenge
in trying to stop speeders there's so
many of them it's it's a matter of where
do I go Brennan says the department has
found on average drivers are going seven
or eight miles over the speed limit but
the faster driver goes the longer it
takes to stop
the NTSB identified more than 100,000
deaths due to speeding between 2005 and
2014 that's nearly as many killed in
alcohol involved crashes every mile an
hour that you increase by you're
increasing your likelihood of a crash
Robert's son Walt is the acting NTSB
chairman this study showed that we can
improve the way that we set speed limits
and enforce speed limits the Safety
Board is calling for expanding the use
of speed cameras only 14 states in
Washington DC currently use them and
only rarely on freeways where drivers go
the fastest another recommendation
encourages installing point-to-point
enforcement used in Australia and the UK
where a driver can be ticketed for
getting from point A to point B faster
than the time it would take by following
the speed limit police use radar or
laser based detectors to spot speeders
they can also follow a car called pacing
to confirm it's going too fast
captain Grenon says it's about targeting
enforcement to try to prevent deadly
crashes we're looking at where these
accidents occurred how can we change
people's behaviors in terms of speeding
and driving more safely I think the
biggest way to do that is just by being
present out there Virginia does not
currently allow speed cameras and we
should tell you deaths on the roads have
soared over the last two years an
estimated 14 percent to around 40,000
and the NTSB says an unintended
consequences of states that have raised
speed limits has been more deaths gale
all right thank you Chris